what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and I want somewhere that to
rub off on to you so you take that thing
that's in here and unleash it into the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're continuing the how
billionaires think success advice from
the top series volume four and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
make sure to put it in quotes and leave
in comments below it'll inspire other
people but as you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
every time is a perfect time to start a
business there's no bad times if you do
the work if you do the preparation
you'll know when it's time and it
doesn't mean that it won't be a little
bit scary but you know it's you'll know
and you don't have to quit the daytime
job if you don't feel that all that
comfortable and you can give it a run at
night but whatever works for you now
with the internet you've got all the
choices in the world and you can just go
out there do your own thing and and you
know set up a business part-time
we've had this tradition for I don't
know probably seven or eight years at
the company where every week we have a
QA where where our employees can come
and ask me any question that they want
about what's going on and what the what
the direction of the company is or
questions or things that they read about
in the press or that their friends who
use the product what what they're asking
them and um it's been this really
important tradition for us both because
we really believe in an openness and
communication and that's kind of what
Facebook is all about but it's also
really important for for me and for
running the company to be able to get
feedback right and and to be able to
learn what's on people's minds what our
what our employees and folks who were
who are part of our team are thinking
about and and just kind of a lot of the
time there are good questions that
people ask that changed the way that we
that we think about what we're building
and what we're here to do in the world
and that often make us go think and
reevaluate how we should be approaching
different problems
you know there is there's a very thin
dividing line between success and
failure when you start a business from
scratch and you know if you don't have
enough money to pay the bills
you go the wrong side of that dividing
line and if you can somehow get enough
money to pay the bills
you stay the right side of that dividing
line and and you know we I've always you
know I've always been running running
running faster than perhaps I should me
and I've have great difficulty saying no
to things so keep on taking on new
things and and you know we've we've just
managed to stay the right side of the
dividing line over the last 50 years in
business but but equally in those early
days when you when you're starting a
business without any financial backing
it's it's it's easy to slip the wrong
side and and in fact you know most
entrepreneurs do do slip the wrong side
and the poor word the important thing is
then just to you know pick yourself up
and you know start again and if it
doesn't work at that time keep keep
going until you do succeed and not to
give up I have young filmmakers come up
to me and say you know give me some
advice for doing this and I say don't
put limitations on yourself other people
will do that for you don't do it to
yourself don't bet against yourself and
and take risks NASA has this has this
phrase that they like failure is not an
option but failure has to be an option
in art and an exploration because it's a
leap of faith and no important endeavor
that required innovation was done
without risk you have to be willing to
take those risks so that's the thought I
would leave you with is it in whatever
you're doing
failure is an option what fear is not
there's a Latin expression which i think
is great I love it was in a now very old
movie called the Dead Poets Society but
the line of the movie was carpe diem
seize the day the opportunities are
there but you got to reach out and pick
them up you've got to grab at them some
of you may have already done that at the
you and your classes and other students
that you met in your extracurricular
activities but grab them don't be afraid
to make a mistake because you know what
you can do if you grab the wrong one
drop it and pick up another one it's
okay
seize the day I think back of all of the
the luck but also the times that were in
front of me to seize the day I don't
know what got me to drop out of Business
School and come to Microsoft my parents
thought I was a whack job neither one of
them graduated college and they thought
this was really a wild idea I was lucky
I seize the day Microsoft one day some
guys fly in from from IBM and all of a
sudden we figure out we could actually
provide all the software they need for
this thing that became the personal
computer people Bill Paul they had the
wisdom to seize the day when that
opportunity presented itself and yet
when you think of all the opportunities
when I think back of all the
opportunities I've had the one that was
most important was an opportunity I got
1969 sitting in my junior high school
class I was in a public junior high not
very stimulated at the time and over the
loudspeaker they said that what private
high school in our area that I'd never
heard of was giving scholarship tests
that weekend I told my mother I wanted
to take him she said that's fine as long
as you get a scholarship because we
can't afford to
you there but that's really where I got
switched down switched on and math
switched on personally energized in a
way that never never could be turned
back and I'm very thankful for that
opportunity yes there's a lot of luck in
opportunity but there's a lot of seizing
the day and I encourage you all to reach
out and carpe diem really seize the
opportunities that are in front of you
I don't wish to alienate people here
with about what I'm about to say but you
know your destiny is in your hands and I
had succeeded because I had to no one
salted anything out for me I didn't ask
go to any government and said pretty
please find me some work please and do
something for me because it was a waste
of bloody time simply that a waste of
time and if I was going to do something
I had to do it myself that's it and and
I would say to every one of you here
don't sit around relying upon magically
some government going to create an
environment that's going to make it easy
for you to find work and find jobs
you've got to go out there and fight for
it yourself I'm sorry to say I can't
give you any other any other form of
advice if you want something bad enough
you do it and if you look at some of
these wannabes that make themselves
television stars or and pop stars and
all that type of stuff they have a
desire to want to be famous
and they don't stop until they're
recognized and they do and half the
people that you see on television these
days in the entertainment industry are
those that added determination that
wanted to do it and I'll add a little
rider to that none of them can bloody
sing
[Music]
not helpful right I mean you didn't find
that helpful answer but you're gonna
control your destiny I'm telling you no
one else is gonna do it not unless
you've got a Rich Dad have you got a
rich dad a rich uncle no well then
that's it you're gonna have to do it
yourself
the funny thing is with enough
persistence most things that seem
impossible become possible I'm always
amazed at how often you can turn things
around and people take no for an answer
too easily
you know it's whether you're trying to
achieve a goal like get into business
school or my green card was the same way
I left the job that had sponsored me but
I still got my green card even though no
lawyer would take me
I became my own lawyer got my green card
without working for while I was at
business school and I did it perfectly
legally I my strategy there was if I
couldn't convince immigration I'd
confuse them and I did and they gave me
my green card
trust your gut it's so important to
trust your gut
you know I saw a man speak one time and
he said I'll prove to you in four words
there's no such thing as a bad idea and
he said Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles ha
ha so I'm here today to prove to you in
two words there's no such thing as a bad
idea and that's footless pantyhose so no
matter what your ideas are you're doing
something better than your competitors
that's why you're in business you've
thought of an idea that's why you're
here and and then be prepared for the
opportunity
when you go out into the world you
should try to stand up against the trend
even though it's my enemy literally it
might cost your job it might cost your
promotion
but in the end think for yourself be
innovative try me I'm not telling you go
in and tell them what to do you've got
to be careful about that obviously but
but if you have ideas go slam the table
don't worry about it come up with your
own imagination
to be sure as if you want to be the next
language is that you have to have a very
big heart you have to take quite a lot
of risk calculated risk first of all you
have to make sure that you're honest you
must make sure that you don't destroy
the name you know because your name is
very important that the most valuable
asset that you have waiting for the way
if you don't have a good name even the
banks doesn't matter how big you are
they're not going to touch each one so
you must make sure that I have a very
very good name and number three you have
to make sure that you see that look
nothing is impossible once you say that
yes nothing is impossible it means that
you can actually achieve that target
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video I'd love to
know what did you think of it what was a
piece of advice that you're going to
take some kind of immediate action on
somehow in your life or in your business
leave it down in the comments below
really curious to find out thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
[Music]